Cloud or edge. Why not? Both.
Okay.
Hello world,
it's Saroj and until recently released a
toolkit for developers called open Vino
to help build computer vision applications
that can be used at the edge or in
the cloud.
Open Beano stands for open visual
inference and neural network optimization.
The toolkit is available for both windows
and Linux platforms and it enables us
to use convolutional neural networks
for computer vision at the edge.
It also supports heterogeneous
execution across Intel's computer vision
accelerators using a common API for
the CPU Intel integrated graphics,
the Intel Mobidius neural compute stick,
which I already made a video about.
An FPGA basically develop once,
deploy anywhere and since computer
vision can be difficult to master,
it includes an easy to use library of
CBE functions and pre optimized kernels.
This can be applied to a whole range
of applications like face detection,
object detection and
license plate recognition,
which we'll demo in this video.
Using these dependencies.
It's inference engine can run deep
learning models easily and its model
optimizer imports converts and optimizes
models that were trained in standard
frameworks into a format
and usable by Intel tools.
Like the inference engine. If you don't
feel like training your own model,
the toolkit comes with a
bunch of different pretrained
models you can use at the
low level.
The toolkit includes support for both
the open CV and open VX computer vision
libraries,
especially optimized for Intel hardware.
It also has an included media SDK
that offers us access to hardware,
accelerated video codecs
and frame processing,
and it enables the use of the popular
open cl library on the GPU or CPU for
Intel processors.
Optimizing and deploying one of these
models is relatively easy. First,
we just configure the model optimizer
for whichever framework we're using,
including tensorflow on x,
mx net and cafe.
Then we can convert a trained model
to produce an optimized intermediate
representation of the model based on the
trained networked apology weights and
bias values.
We can then test the
model in the intermediate
representation format using the
inference engine in the target environment
via either the provided inference
engine validation application or
one of several sample applications.
Lastly,
we can integrate the inference engine
into our application to deploy the model
in the target environment.
So let's demo the example of using open
Beano to perform vehicle detection,
which will detect a car
and it's licensed plate.
We'll want to use a
pretrained model for this,
specifically the faster or CNN model.
This is actually to neural networks
eight regional proposal network that
generates region proposals and a
network using these proposals to detect
objects.
The output of the RPN is a bunch of boxes
that will be examined by a classifier
and regressor to eventually
check the occurrence of objects.
The RPN thus predicts the possibility
of a box being background or foreground
and refines it in the first step.
The input image goes through
the convolutional network,
which will output a set of convolutional
feature maps on the last convolutional
layer. Then a sliding window. It's
run spatially on these feature maps.
For each sliding window.
A set of nine anchor boxes are generated,
which all have the same center,
but with three different aspect ratios
and three different scales. Lastly,
the spatial features extracted from these
convolutional feature maps are given
to a smaller network, which has two
tasks, classification and regression.
The output of the regressor
decides the predicted bounding box.
The output of the classification sub
network is a probability p indicating
whether the predicted box contains
an object or it's from a background.
We can download the weights,
metadata,
and model weights directly from
Github and Dropbox respectively.
It's a cafe model so we can run it
through the model optimizer using the
following command in terminal.
This will create an
intermediate representation
that our inference engine can
serve when we run the application will
receive an output file labeled zero dot
BMP.
When we opened that file,
we'll see the detected car
and closed in rectangles.
It outputs the list of classes of the
detected objects along with the respected
confidence values and the coordinates of
the rectangles and the standard output
stream.
As you can see,
this high performance
library makes computer vision
really simple for anyone to
try. I've linked to some great resources
to learn more in the video description,
including a link to the free
download on the open VNL website.
Please subscribe for
more programming videos,
and for now I've got to keep it
open source, so thanks for watching.